اولا ال
ما بني في 80 سنه او بالتحديد عندنا هنا
يمكن 50 او 60 سنه
من طبائع الامور
كذلك ما اشرت اليه
لابد ان يكون لدينا استراتيجيه وطنيه
تلتزم بها كافه القطاعات الحكوميه
هناك او في تباين بينهم
وتوجيهات عليا همم تحسم الامور لكن مع
الاسف يعني ما زالت بعض الجهات همم يعني
لا اقول متراحيه لكن غير مقدره همم اعذرني
من ال همم لكن ما زالت بعض الجهات غير
مقدره لخطوره همم رموز هذه الجماعات
وخطوره هذا الفكر بالتالي يلزمنا
استراتيجيه وطنيه نلتزم بها جميعا ليس فقط
القطاعات الحكوميه حتى قطاعات همم
القطاع الخاص القطاع الخيري او القطاع
الثالث كلها لابد ان همم تلتزم بهذه
الاستراتيجيه دكتور اشكرك شكرا جزيل على
تواجدك معي اذا كان لك اضافات تريد ان
تضيف هذه
الاضافه الاخيره التي اود ان اضيف ان
جماعات التفسير السياسي الاسلام الاخوان
والسروريه وغيرهم همم الحقيقه انهم همم ضد
دوله المواطنه
والدوله الوطنيه لماذا لان همم دوله تدعو
الى ارساء السلم المجتمعي التسامح نبذ
الكراهيه همم هؤلاء افعالهم ومالات ما
قاموا به ضرب السلم الاجتماعي ونشر همم
يعني ثقافه الكراهيه الحقيقه ان سمو ولي
العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان له دور كبير
في مكافحه سواء همم التطرف الفساد وهذا
الفساد الفكري همم من اخطر انواع الفساد
ف- همم يعني سعه الى نشر ثقافه التعايش
وهمم السلام والتسامح داخليا واقليميا
ودوليا